for most of our history human technology
consisted of our brains
fire and sharp sticks while fire and
sharp sticks became power plants and
nuclear weapons
the biggest upgrade has happened to our
brains since the 1960s
the power of our brain machines has kept
growing exponentially
allowing computers to get smaller and
more powerful at the same time
but this process is about to meet its
physical limits
computer parts are approaching the size
of an atom
to understand why this is a problem we
have to clear up some basics
[Music]
a computer is made up of very simple
components doing very simple things
representing data the means of
processing it and control mechanisms
computer chips contain modules which
contain logic gates
which contain transistors a transistor
is the simplest form of a data processor
in computers
basically a switch that can either block
or open the way for information coming
through
this information is made up of bits
which can be set to either 0 or 1.
combinations of several bits are used to
represent more complex information
transistors are combined to create logic
gates which still do very simple stuff
for example an and gate sends an output
of 1 if all of its inputs are 1
and an output of 0 otherwise
combinations of logic gates
finally form meaningful modules say for
adding two numbers
once you can add you can also multiply
and once you can multiply
you can basically do anything since all
basic operations are literally simpler
than first grade math you can imagine a
computer as a group of seven-year-olds
answering really basic math questions a
large enough bunch of them could compute
anything from astrophysics
to zelda however with parts getting
tinier and tinier quantum physics are
making things tricky
in a nutshell a transistor is just an
electric switch
electricity is electrons moving from one
place to another
so a switch is a passage that can block
electrons from moving in one direction
today a typical scale for transistors is
14 nanometers
which is about eight times less than the
hiv viruses diameter
and 500 times smaller than a red blood
cells
as transistors are shrinking to the size
of only a few atoms
electrons may just transfer themselves
to the other side of a blocked passage
via a process called quantum tunneling
in the quantum realm
physics works quite differently from the
predictable ways we're used to
and traditional computers just stop
making sense
we are approaching a real physical
barrier for our technological progress
to solve this problem scientists are
trying to use these
unusual quantum properties to their
advantage by building quantum computers
in normal computers bits are the
smallest units of information
quantum computers use qubits which can
also be set to one of two values
a cubic can be any two level quantum
system such as a spin in a magnetic
field
or a single photon zero and one of this
system's possible states
like the photons horizontal or vertical
polarization
in the quantum world the qubit doesn't
have to be in just one of those
it can be in any proportions of both
states at once
this is called superposition but as soon
as you test its value
say by sending the photon through a
filter it has to decide to be either
vertically
or horizontally polarized so as long as
it's unobserved
the qubit is in a superposition of
probabilities for zero and one
and you can't predict which it will be
but the instance you measure it
it collapses into one of the definite
states
superposition is a game changer four
classical bits can be in one of two to
the power of four different
configurations at a time
that's 16 possible combinations out of
which you can use just
one four qubits in superposition however
can be in all of those 16 combinations
at once
this number grows exponentially with
each extra qubit
20 of them can already store a million
values in parallel
a really weird and unintuitive property
qubits can have
is entanglement a close connection that
makes each of the qubits react to a
change in the other state
instantaneously
no matter how far they are apart this
means that when measuring just one
entangled qubit
you can directly deduce properties of
its partners without having to look
qubit manipulation is a mind bender as
well
a normal logic gate gets a simple set of
inputs
and produces one definite output a
quantum gate
manipulates an input of superpositions
rotates probabilities
and produces another superposition as
its output
so a quantum computer sets up some
qubits applies quantum gates to entangle
them and manipulate probabilities
and finally measures the outcome
collapsing superpositions
to an actual sequence of zeros and ones
what this means is that you get the
entire lot of calculations that are
possible with your setup
all done at the same time ultimately you
can only measure one of the results
and it will only probably be the one you
want so you may have to double check and
try again
but by cleverly exploiting superposition
and entanglement
this can be exponentially more efficient
than would ever be possible on a normal
computer
so while quantum computers will probably
not replace our home computers
in some areas they are vastly superior
one of them is database searching
to find something in a database a normal
computer may have to test every single
one of its entries
quantum algorithms need only the square
root of that time
which for large databases is a huge
difference
the most famous use of quantum computers
is running i.t
security right now your browsing email
and banking data
is being kept secure by an encryption
system in which you give everyone a
public key to encode messages only you
can decode
the problem is that this public key can
actually be used to calculate your
secret private key
luckily doing the necessary math on any
normal computer
would literally take years of trial and
error but a quantum computer with
exponential speed up
could do it in a breeze another really
exciting new use is
simulations simulations of the quantum
world are very intense on resources
and even for bigger structures such as
molecules
they often lack accuracy so why not
simulate quantum physics
with actual quantum physics quantum
simulations could provide new insights
on proteins that might revolutionize
medicine
right now we don't know if quantum
computers will be just a very
specialized tool
or a big revolution for humanity we have
no idea where the limits of technology
are
and there's only one way to find out
video is supported by the australian
academy of science which promotes and
supports
excellence in science learn more about
this topic and
others like it at nova.org.au it was a
blast to work with them
so go check out their site our videos
are also made possible by your support
on patreon.com
if you want to support us and become
part of the kotzkazak bird army
check out our patreon page